we are talking about game of ferns at
the London comic-con your character is
really quite something isn't he what is
it like to play him as an actor it's
pretty awesome it's it's one of those
things that probably only come around
well unless your Jackie Chan only come
around once in a while because you know
I have a reputation of being a theatre
actor in this country and a lot of the
things that I've done I've played a lot
of the fools and clowns in Shakespeare
and that's been great but suddenly I get
the chance to play a kind of this
unconventional zen-like swordmaster
which is it's a really amazing it's very
very
I can't really describe it in any other
way except it's so thoroughly because of
course you get to play a character that
is cooler than yourself which is amazing
in itself so and because of his you know
his importance to areas storyline which
i think is an amazing storyline and will
continue to kind of grow and become more
more exciting and thrilling and
surprising it feels like a real honor it
feels like a real honor and and the most
exciting thing of course is working and
learning those sword fights I mean some
of it was me working with William Hobbs
who is an amazing teacher when it came
to learning the vocabulary of what the
water dance was going to be and the
other stuff is working with Buster
Reeves where he choreographed these
amazing fights for me to do which was
just brilliant I mean it's got a huge
cast but every single one of them and I
think this is something to do with it
being an ensemble everyone is
is so amazing I really why do we do
these things because everyone every
actor goes on I'm working with amazing
people and they're all amazing money it
really is the truth that you work with
people who really inspire you people
like James Cosmo two actresses like
Maisie Williams who you know you've got
one extreme in the other someone with so
much experience and so much to teach
anyone who works with him and you know
someone who has no experience but who
just brings like a kind natural quality
which is you know you learn a lot from
now you know because there's no she
doesn't overthink things like just in
the moment really present and works very
very hard and it's not like it is
effortless for her it's just that if she
makes it look at this
so it's people you work with it's been
working in a creative environment that
that is inspiring and makes you do your
best work you could obviously see what
you enjoy by working with the other
actors but what do you think the fans
enjoy about your character because he's
a great sword master isn't he he's
unconventional and these these teachers
that go from you know obi-wan Kenobi in
Star Wars to mr. Miyagi in the The
Karate Kid you know they're like these
characters are unconventional teachers
and unconventional teachers are exciting
because you don't expect that to happen
you know you don't expect
the things that they teach you to learn
it's like with anything you know when
you learn things not necessarily by
someone telling you this is the way to
do them you learn them in a round away
roundabout way and and I think the
really important thing about Serio is
that although he's kind of her and he is
kind of enigmatic he really really loves
area and you know and these people don't
know each other very well but there's an
immediate bond and her Dave and Dan
saying that you know this character has
to has to you know Aria has to love him
like a father you know because he
listens to her for the first time apart
from her father is the only person who
listens turn takes us seriously in
and doesn't treat her like a good in
fact calls a boy all the time so so you
know that probably likes that because
she hates being a little girl that if
you matter so yeah it's it's great and
you know those kind of beat those kind
of characters go throughout history you
know yeah always
archetypal and I'm sure George Martin
have had you know those characters in
his head when he thought about who's
Serio is going to be so if you have any
sort of inspirations that use your own
for playing him I mean even in your own
life experiences with teachers as a
child or as a drama school obviously I'm
guessing people weren't teaching you
through Melissa's third play but even
you know what I mean yeah I mean I drew
on those things that I just told you
about those films you know Karate Kid
Star Wars you know those are the things
that are very inspiring to me and things
like her up with you know
and in a way they can be a bit trite but
it's amazing the things that inspire you
and for me the you know film has always
been an inspiration to me even in my
theater work it has a profound effect I
mean we all contextualize things by the
things that we've seen or heard or read
or you know all of those things matter
and also working with William Hobbs who
was the guy that I work with in my for
my prep he's a man that's been working
for decades
doing fight choreography learning you
know teaching people how to use swords
everything from the duelists Ridley
Scott's the duelists to Dangerous
Liaisons to you know he's done that he's
done it all and you know he's in his 70s
and he's an amazing teacher and he was
really good inspiration you know I
learned a lot about what Syria was from
just working with him so that was very
immediate yeah do you think you'd be a
good teacher in real life yourself
that's a good question I'd like to think
so but I mean I have done some teaching
I've taught I've tortured drama schools
but I'm - I'm like - I get distracted
easily so I would you know maybe that
might work but I just find I think I
don't have the dedication or the focus
and to teach one subject for very long
because I just go oh oh what's that over
there and I've kind of like want to do
that you know we're supposed to be doing
one play we end up doing another or you
know nothing really ever kind of like I
don't you know so so I think teaching is
hard I would never underestimate how
hard it is to teach just any of your
kind of Shakespearean acting it helps
you with this because it's very kind of
big and brand has it helped you at all
yeah I would say so I don't think it was
necessary particularly because I talk
like this in the show but but it is
there's something about the scale of it
it's kind of slightly heightened we
don't talk in a cloak or modern way I
think maybe that's one of the reasons
why you choose British actors to do a
series like this because you know we'll
really want to kind of hear West Coast
acts accents talking about winners
Connie
goddamnit you know that doesn't that
doesn't quite you know like work but no
disrespect to American actors by the way
no disrespect it it has something to do
with the poetry the way things are
written in a slightly heightened way and
it's it's kind of has a certain kind of
scale to it
yeah which which kind of a thing suits
being able to talk in that way really
it's not that there is a way it's just I
think maybe British actors are better at
it oh my god I'm gonna be shot down in
flames for saying this than anyone else
but there you go it's out there I think
I mean it there is a thing where it's
nowhere if it's Roman or medieval
although all those kind of things there
is a recourse to British actors that
Studios films TV always seems to have
their they yeah and I think it's great
for us and I think it's great for
American actors because I feel like
there's been a big crossover between us
they're you know even going back ten
years ago you know we kept in our own
but it's you know there's been a real
crossover mainly because of things like
the wire and True Blood and you know
even going back to like Deadwood you
know those series where you had a real
mixture of American and British actors
and and I'm really glad about it because
it helps all of our
asked to do more interesting work you
know there's no other way again you
can't describe it any other way in
America they make a lot of TV and TV
seems to be the future people have
almost it's become the medium that
everyone wants to tell stories in
because you have more time and it's
great when it comes to adapting books
and even like two hours even now they're
pushing you know movies are now pushing
three hours sometimes over three hours
people are realizing that it's film is a
very limited medium and because of HBO
and its success and then that they dozen
so well because it does things for the
right reason it gets right creative
people to you know create these shows
people suddenly go yeah this is the
future if you want to tell a story we do
it in a TV series so you have the time
and you have a little bit more space to
breathe and you know you have builder
production values the design the
costumes and locations I mean how does
that feed into how you play the part as
an actor
there's no acting required
it's true though there really I think
you leave I think I was talking to Finn
Jones about this and we were doing a Q&A
in New Zealand and I think that kind of
question came up and is it really you
know you walk into this place I've run
out of photographs run out of
photographs I've sold them all
the you know you walk into the studio is
rainy it's cold it's Belfast you walk
into the studio the paintball and they
recreated a castle room in King's
Landing and it's there's a balcony and
the Sun is streaming in through the
balcony and they've done something to
the to the sound so that when you walk
on the stone which isn't necessarily
stone it has this kind of like resonant
you know kind of sound it sounds like
you're in a large large room and you
look out over King's Landing and it's
just a painted backdrop but it's painted
so amazingly well but it you would not
believe that it isn't painted all of
those things mean that when you turn up
and you're in your costume and you kind
of go all that detail you just kind of
breathe it I mean it sounds so
pretentious to say it but it really is
you breathe it in and it's like just
open your mouth and you just say
Alliance slightly different for me
because I had to have know how to use a
sword and you know that took a lot of
work but it really is it's kind of
amazing to work on a scale
you know where you know if we don't
finish a scene we don't rush to finish
it we finish it and we do it properly
and if that means kind of pushing things
forward into the next day then we do it
and that's kind of luxury you just don't
find very often in now we know your
characters in a letter quite an
interesting place hasn't hey so what do
you think fans of the show can look
forward to coming up I know what I am
looking forward to season three but I
feel like if I say what I'm looking
forward to it it's almost like a spoiler
in itself but you know it's gonna be
bigger it's gonna be just when you
thought that you couldn't be surprised
or shocked by the series it will shock
you and surprise you even further than
you could possibly imagine and the
development of the characters goes in a
place where it just I mean it this is
what's so brilliant about the series is
that
you just don't know what's gonna happen
and george RR martin is a ruthless and
when you have a story where no one is
safe it means that anything can happen
and i think that is what makes it such a
compelling serious because even the
people who know the books will be
surprised if you manage to work your way
through all the books that are there so
far I'm on book three part one and I
took it away with me when we went
travelling around the world just
recently and of course I didn't I didn't
open it once there was just too many
parties to go to
so it was like yeah so I'm gonna get
back into it because it's great and I've
been enjoying it but I you know I I put
it down and then I just again I just get
distracted I get distracted by the book
says the other thing you know someone
and there's always someone kind of
giving me a book or is that there's a
book that I have to walk read which is a
work-related I'm like oh I'm gonna read
this book so I've always got about five
books on the go at any one time one of
the biggest questions I ever get asked
is did he die what happened to Syrio
Forel and I don't know
you don't know anything could happen
it's fantasy it's like you know maybe
maybe George who changes his mind and
thinks no he's gonna come back or you
know which I'm always hoping for there
was this kind of theory that jaqen
H'ghar is is also cereal but but that
wouldn't make any difference to me
because they'll just get a different
actor to play him because there'll be a
different face wouldn't it
so that was isn't gonna work in your
wildest fantasies talking about
fantasies what would you like to see
happen with Serie A Game of Thrones
talking anything can happen what would
you like to see happen well like
anything is in that isn't necessarily in
the books is that when she goes to
Braavos is she really
giveme unites again that would be great
that would be great but completely
unexpectedly you like one series after
another see you know season goes by
people completely forgotten about him
and then like in season 7 you know she
walks into a room and he's sitting in a
chair hey that would be brilliant I hope
you're gonna email George straight after
this and miss Jessel I'm gonna speak to
him I will be speaking to him fantastic
but it's Audacity lovely to speak to you
and I hope we see you turning around in
a chair and Susan Severn Mr Bond I've
been expecting you
you